This is your ship, correct?
Oh, yeah!
That's my ship, it's my pride and joy.
The Invincible.
I mean, it's our ship actually.
This is the captain so
technically they are in charge.
Oh!
You're in charge!
So...
This ship is your responsibility.
I swear...
If one more thing blows up on my ship
I'm gonna lose it!
WOAH!
Warning!
Large object on collision course with ship.
Brace for impact.
It's up to the Captain!
They haven't let us down yet.
Captain! Something is very wrong-
But we seem to have this situation all under control.
We have to fix this now or we're all gonna die!
Captain?!
It all comes down-
The Captain wouldn't do that...
-to bad leadership.
CAPTAIN!!
Have you ever considered that
there is no right answer?
Have we been here before...?
Every mistake has cost the
lives of people who've trusted you!
Which means that if I'm
seeing it, I must be crazy!
But I'm not crazy!
Everything has to end-
I go and I come back and I go and
I come back and I ALWAYS COME BACK!
-and everything... has to begin.
Ugh... Captain...
I don't feel so-
HURGH!
Ow.